somehow my philosophy in life goes back
to rule essentially means that I always
want to feel like I'm coming back to a
place where I feel like I can rest and
relax and feel it calm on the inside
Lana is a fellow YouTuber with over a
million subscribers and her channel is
all about a little bit more of a chill
approach to life and a mindful approach
to productivity in the episode we talk
about a bunch of stuff including how she
grew her audience while still working a
full-time job we talk about Lana's take
on the concept of productivity and what
it means to work towards your goals but
in a way that's actually Mindful and
enjoyable not just hustle culture Vibes
somehow we feel like if we have more of
a calm approach to things we're not as
productive you know it's not as
efficient I can at least feel sometimes
like okay why am I not feeling too
stressed about this does that mean that
I'm slacking even if I'm getting as much
done and getting it done better than I
would have had otherwise there is
something in me and maybe you and other
people where you kind of feel like being
productive means that you need to feel
like you're running around and we talk a
little bit about the challenges and the
ups and downs of online dating I don't
really buy this whole thing it has to be
a hell yes from the beginning does that
happen I have a hard time believing
people are like Oh Yeah from like the
moment I saw this person it was just
perfect and I knew I think most people
land somewhere in between
just a very quick thing before we get
started if you have not yet subscribed
to the podcast either on YouTube or in
your favorite podcast app of choice then
please do it really helps us out a lot
Lana you have just hit a million
subscribers so congratulations on that
front and my understanding is that you
started YouTube in 2018 so that would
have been when you were like 22 years
old yes what would what did your life
look like before then and how did we get
to the point where you decided I'm gonna
film myself and upload a video to
YouTube
so I
was working in finance had
nine to five regular sort of job and I
always liked photography and I'm taking
photos just for fun and I've been pretty
creative I've liked writing and things
like that
and so I was living in the U.S for two
years working in finance and some other
things and I was actually posting Vlogs
from there but they're not on my channel
anymore thankfully
um because I just wanted to try and see
what I could
create out of nothing I had no idea what
I was interested in doing or talking
about or if I wanted to be a vlogger or
someone who sits down and talks to the
camera
and then
I was like okay when I moved back home
to Sweden I'm gonna give this thing more
of a try like I'm gonna try and actually
put some effort into the videos
um
and
I think even in Sweden my first couple
of videos which also don't exist anymore
I wear Vlogs and then I made a video
it's like a little short film-ish on my
channel which is like the first video
that is up there now
and I had a lot of fun and I think he
got 200 views or something and like five
comments and I was like wow that's crazy
200 people watch this video and then
that motivated me to keep creating more
videos and
I did and here we are at a million which
is crazy so when you made that video
that got 200 views did you still have
the day job then yeah so you're working
in finance as well in Sweden yeah not in
finance more like a marketing ish and
then I quit my job but first I told
myself I was like when I hit like 30k
that's like reasonable to quit my job
and then I was like that's too far and
then I was like when I hit 20K and 10K
and then I just made it less and less
and less
and then I think I quit when I was at
like seven thousand so you had seven
thousand subscribers and he quit the dog
and you quit your job yes surely you
weren't making enough money to sustain
that like how well what was the thought
process I was very lucky at the time I
was living at home uh and I had been
saving all my money to just be able to
sustain for myself for as long as
possible and then very luckily shortly
after
how long after maybe a
couple months I had a video blow up
um gaining like a million views to start
with and then even more and that's what
just took everything off and so the time
from quitting to that point was
very short okay
um so that was I had the algorithm yeah
Gods on my side for sure how many videos
did you make before like I guess roughly
how many videos had you made before that
video blew up
not that many Maybe
10. oh including all the Vlogs and stuff
oh with the Vlogs yeah they're no longer
up yeah
um maybe
20. oh wow okay so I'm kind of guessing
here I'm not sure but roughly so after a
couple of dozen videos you had one yeah
that blew up yeah that's pretty good I
think yeah it's really good so
I've got a lot of friends who also live
with their parents and don't have many
expenses and who work in jobs that they
don't like but they still feel the sense
of oh I can't I can't leave my job
because I need to earn money I need to
have enough like even though the
expenses are zero because they're living
with their parents
um
what was it about like that's it's
pretty unusual to even if you are living
with your parents and you have a job to
just suddenly decide you know what
I'm making basically no money off of
YouTube but I'm gonna quit the job
anyway so what made you like what were
the dots that connected for you to
decide to I guess take that leap I think
in one way it was a very hard decision
because I mean it was it felt kind of
dumb
um quitting having I mean YouTube paid
me maybe a dollar a month or not even
that at that point
um and so on one hand I felt like this
is a very
I'm taking a big risk here
um but I felt kind of safe because I had
my degrees and I was like if things
don't work out I can just still get a
job so I had something safe to kind of
fall back on if things were to not turn
out well so that definitely helped
having that safety net
and then they were just it sounds kind
of cliche but something in me was like
you have to do this because if you're
not going to do it you're just gonna
keep thinking about it and thinking
about it and you're not going to let it
go and I was very unfulfilled at that
job that I had not that the job was
necessarily even a bad job I just
couldn't stop thinking about YouTube and
I became obsessed I would read about it
and watch videos of people talking about
YouTube and becoming a YouTuber and well
gear you should have and how you should
speak and what you should think about
and I just became obsessed like every
lunch break that I had I would consume
how to YouTube content and
um
I think I just felt like if I continue
being this obsessed and wanting to try
this thing so much and if I stay
consistent
how is it not going to work out I think
it kind of had that mentality nice yeah
that's great well yeah this is the thing
I think it's so true like if you if you
feel like you enjoy the thing and you
are consistent with it and produce
videos that are sort of vaguely getting
better over time
like like it's it's hard to imagine a
world in which it doesn't at least work
out in some kind of way yeah that's what
I was I think thinking and
if you my idea was is if you feel like
you're not really into it like let's say
you want to be a YouTuber but you're
kind of like yeah it looks kind of fun
but I don't know I'm not very into it
maybe that's going to be difficult
because you're not gonna likely not
gonna see any growth or numbers and
you're gonna feel silly for putting in
all this time when no one is watching
you or caring about you
um so you think I think you need to
really
feel like regardless of how many people
are watching or engaging in the
beginning I'm so obsessed with this
thing that I'm just gonna keep going and
going yeah it's about like enjoying
enjoying the journey and not just being
fixated on a particular outcome oh
absolutely
um Okay so
at the time you quit the job did you
tell yourself I'm going to try this for
a year or two years or six months like
or did you say I'm a Mr Beast of like
I'm gonna be a YouTuber or I'm gonna die
like what was your approach to this I
think that's what I was feeling uh but I
told my mom because she was like okay
well
how long
um I mean obviously you can still live
at home but how long are you gonna be
jobless basically because I think no
parent you know wants to see their child
jobless
um
and I think I told her like I'm gonna
give this a year or six months something
like that not too long
um and she was like okay sounds pretty
reasonable so I think it's good to give
yourself some sort of a timeline
because it also motivates you in a way
to really work at it and stay consistent
and give it your all
did you have like a time when you
started
um I didn't quit my job until like three
years into the YouTube thing I went so
like I was very much overlapping yeah
and then the reason I quit was because I
was always going to take a break anyway
and then so it all worked out fairly
trivially almost but I always feel like
I'm I'm very risk-averse and so the
thought of quitting my job I'd have been
like like
even in a like especially in a
non-medical job I would have thought
about off but there's going to be a gap
on my resume and like people are going
to be like oh you left your job and then
it's going to be harder for me to find
another job how did you think about the
whole Gap in the CVS I think that was
the scariest thing and that was the main
thing some people try discouraging me
saying well there's going to be a gap in
your resume and how is that going to
look for future employers I was like I'm
not going to need a future employer I
tried having that sort of mindset
because yeah you I mean you want to
think of the risks and what like having
a plan B is important but you also don't
want to make that your reality you want
your reality to be no but this is going
to work out and it's going to go great
and I'm not gonna need any of that even
though you should be aware of that I
think
um
so yeah I mean it was a big risk but
I also feel like again having a safety
net and feeling like someone is going to
hire me even if I haven't worked for a
few months I think I don't think no one
is going to want me ever so it's not
that serious it doesn't work out yeah I
think I think there's a lot of um
fear mongering and in the sort of job
finding space where and I
I guess a lot of the narratives that we
hear are that oh it's so hard to find a
job in the current market and like it's
so hard to get a job anywhere
but I don't know it like maybe I'm just
so out of touch with how hard it is to
get a job but like basically everyone I
know found it reasonably easy to get a
job and maybe they might struggle to
find another one that pays more money
but it's definitely fairly easy enough
to get a job and take a bit of a pickup
and so really the risk in inverted
commas is literally just the Delta
between the job that you're able to get
easily and the job you currently have
whereas I think a lot of people think of
it as like oh my God I'm gonna be
homeless and broke and it sort of
there's a lot of it's it's easy to
catastrophize the situation and maybe I
mean it depends on your situation if
you're someone who you know maybe you
don't have any safety net at all and
quitting a job that you struggle very
hard to get and maybe for some reason
you know you're
you're job opportunities is quite narrow
then you're gonna have a lot more to
lose as opposed to if you have more so I
think it depends on your situation but
it's also thinking okay what would I
rather do do I wanna stay safe and
continue doing this job that I'm doing
and you know be quite unhappy and
unfulfilled but safe or can I take this
risk without ruining my life if things
don't work out but the outcome could be
something very positive I might end up
very fulfilled and happy and doing
something that I deeply care about and
I'm good at so it's all the risk in
return absolutely thing it's like
weighing it all up yeah just a quick
announcement from one of our sponsors
and we'll get right back to the episode
and this episode is brought to you by
Heights Heights is a brain care smart
supplement that I've been taking every
morning for the last 12 months I love it
so much that I actually became friends
with the founder Dan who we actually had
on season one of the Deep dive podcast
we also have an interview this season
with neuroscientist and psychiatrist Dr
Tara swart who's the chief science
officer of heights and I like the
product so much that I actually became
an angel investor in the company it's
great everything they do is completely
evidence-based so on their website
they've got a list of all 20-something
micronutrients that they've got in these
two capsules along with links to all of
the various scientific papers and
consensuses on why these sorts of
nutrients are good for you and why
they've got them at the appropriate
dosing which they have in the capsules
in the capsules it's super easy to sign
up you just go on the website which is
linked in the show notes and in the
video description and you put in your
address and they send you one of these
little boxes of pills every month or
every quarter now I sign up to the
quarterly subscription so I get three of
these every three months and the
quarterly subscription is is great
because a it's discounted from the
monthly subscription and B if you use
the coupon code Ali 15 ali15 at checkout
then you'll get an extra 15 off the
already discounted price of the
quarterly subscription now obviously
it's ideal if you can actually get all
these micronutrients from your diet that
would be the gold standard but as
studies show 99 of us in the Western
World don't in fact have the absolutely
perfect gold standard Mediterranean diet
I certainly don't I eat a lot of
takeaways and so these two capsules just
two capsules Every Morning has my base
is covered and it's a lot easier to take
just two little capsules with water than
it is to try and drown green sludge or
whatever else other other companies have
in the market that kind of does the same
thing so anyway thank you so much
Heights for sponsoring this episode and
let's get right back to the podcast at
the time in those early days like so the
2017-2018 if someone asked you right
Lana what is your Channel about or what
do you do on YouTube what would you have
said
so I still don't know the answer to that
question
um
still when people ask me what do you do
on YouTube I'm like I don't know I talk
about things that I care about that's
kind of my response which I mean I guess
it is but it's very vague like what does
that mean it doesn't really give an
answer to the question and some may may
say that it's self-help but I don't know
is itself maybe because it's helping
some people so is that self-help maybe I
think I don't really
I think people can Define it as what
they want some people come and saying
it's their safe place and some people
say they're learning things and some
people say you know it's different for
so I think my channel is what others
think it is and that just differs from
person to person back then it was just
exploring I mean I talked about a
variety of things I talked about uh
hookup culture and I talked about
self-improvement and I talked about
productivity and a variety of things and
I still do to an extent so
I don't really know
what do you think my channel is about I
I also don't really like I I feel like I
struggle to answer that question for
myself as well because I guess we both
are sort of in that personal development
t space yeah
but within that we're both fairly Broad
in the sorts of topics we talk about
yeah and our audiences overlap a lot
yeah your thing often comes up as like
you know your audience also works yeah
yeah me too so I think maybe just people
our audiences are just people interested
in
bettering themselves or maybe they just
thinks even if they don't want to better
themselves they just think listening to
topics about those things is important
or interesting I don't know
this might be a difficult one but like
what do you think is it about your
channel that made it get so popular like
loads of people want to become personal
development YouTubers it seems these
days
um whenever I run my YouTuber Academy
like half the people who join want to
become personal development YouTubers
because they're all interested in
personal development and it's like oh I
could study I could become the next Alia
doll I could become the next
non-ablikely because I can talk about
personal development with my own twist
and
I don't know like it strikes me that
realistically very few of them are going
to get to the million subscriber Mark so
what do you think it is that that sort
of was it about your channel that has
touched a chord with people oh great
questions I'm like why do I have million
subscribers I don't know but I think
um
at the time when I was starting a lot of
you that I was watching was quite loud I
think and quite
out there and a little bit not
aggressive but very like
you know the hi everyone you know that
sort of intro and it was very
extroverted maybe I don't really know
how to define it and I think that wasn't
because that's not me as a person and in
the beginning because when I was
studying how to become a YouTuber
um I came across a video saying you need
to talk louder and be more you know
engaging because people are not gonna
watch and yeah that's true for some
people to an extent and I try that and I
just watched back watched the videos
back and I was like that's not me at all
it feels very
manufactured and strained and so I toned
it back and started talking more like
myself a bit slower and you know some
people really cannot watch my videos
without speeding it up I mean you
probably you probably could not I think
I'll watch you in about 3x speed or
something yeah
um but some people well clearly more
than some people were drawn to that and
enjoy the more
kind of quiet slow down pace and style
so maybe that's part of it I think I
don't think that's
as common as the more going louder yeah
I think but it's really hard knowing why
people are watching you really
why do you think you've been so
successful
shooting at block right place at the
right time I think also just yeah but
okay yeah it it is hard to kind of
connect the dots um
I think that
at the time so around 2017 2018 I I
guess both of us sort of got into this
space around the same time so I started
my channel in 2017 but anybody started
making I guess productivity type stuff
2018 2019.
around that time
it was still a somewhat untapped market
like there were people who were big like
Matt and Tom and Nathaniel
and Joey but beyond those four there
were not many people in the space
and so
I think there was space for more voices
to just sort of do the same thing
personal development from a different
sort of twist and I think I had the
unfair advantage of sort of trading off
the doctor thing but like hey I'm a
doctor and I do [ __ ] on the side and
therefore you should listen to me yeah
otherwise I hope the implication of some
of the stuff
now if I were to start a YouTube channel
I don't think I'd try and go straight
for personal development because it's
just too broad I'd probably go for like
Finance or crypto or something and
really just try and have deep expertise
in one particular area why because I
think it's a lot easier to stand out
when you have deep expertise in one area
because I think if I were a YouTuber if
I were just starting out there's no
unfair advantage that I have there's
nothing that helps me stand out from the
crowd whereas if I just got really good
at explaining crypto for example yeah
then I can do that for like a year or
two and then Branch slowly out into the
rest of finance and and I really like
that sort of stuff but do you think that
would be as fun being more like because
now you can kind of make content about
anything you want I know we talked about
this book about relationships that you
talked about and you talk about tech
stuff and productivity and finance and
do you think that's don't you think
that's what keeps it interesting as well
that you can just kind of talk about
what you want I think I think so but I
think
the way I see it is that that is a
privilege that you get to have once
you're already successful
like for example Amazon started out just
selling books if Jeff had tried to sell
everything from day one it's not going
to work so he starts off with books and
then slowly expands out and now Amazon
sells everything
similarly I think my approach to YouTube
would be to start off super Niche and
then slowly expand
and because if I were a new YouTuber and
I made a video of like 10 productivity
hacks no one's watching it but if I made
a video like something really Niche like
how to program an altcoin on the salana
blockchain now there's potentially some
search traffic and I could potentially
get some views that way yeah because
sometimes when I have an issue with like
Premiere Pro or something very specific
and I'll look up that issue on YouTube
and I'll find a video of someone having
like a million views about something
very very specific that I thought
I'm not even gonna find so yeah I think
there's something
to it but I don't know I think
I mean I enjoy being able to talk about
multiple things but also sometimes I
think it would be a lot easier if I just
had like let's say I was just talking
about relationships because then like
the Right audience is really gonna find
me and they're gonna watch all my videos
probably most of them because they're
all on the same topic and that's why
they're there I think when you're
talking about multiple things some
people are like oh I like his Tech stuff
but not his Finance stuff so it's your
views can kind of fluctuate too so yeah
I think it's like pros and cons yeah
what's up what's that how how do you
feel about the The View fluctuation with
your with your channel
um
I think there's always a balance between
finding or creating videos that you
really enjoy where you're like I really
want to talk about this thing and it's
going to be very interesting to create
and the right people are going to
appreciate it a lot but maybe it's not
something that's going to get a lot of
attention because it's just not that
type of video and then you have ideas
that are more okay this is gonna go
pretty well like I'm pretty sure this is
going to perform well but it's not
something very personal or super
exciting I enjoy making it but it's not
as like it doesn't fuel me the way
something else might fill me so I think
finding that balance is difficult
sometimes like do I want to get more
views or do I want this to be like
touch the core of my heart you know what
do you feel about oh I haven't done yeah
100 the same yeah the same dilemma and
it like I was watching a great video
that Mark Manson put out the other day
where he talked about the price of
success and so and so he wrote These
like these two books which did like
ridiculously well like I think he's
probably one of the best-selling authors
in the space like in the in the last
generation but he said that because his
books was so successful he started
playing it safe on his blog and only
writing stuff he knew would resonate
with people
but the reason he was successful in the
first place is because he wrote stuff
that was a bit out there like the subtle
art of not giving a [ __ ] and all that
kind of thing
and then he was like playing it safe and
so he made a YouTube video basically
being like right I'm now going to become
a YouTuber and I'm going to talk about
whatever I want and it seems like a lot
of like almost every creator that I
speak to who has the has this dilemma
between do I Pander to the audience or
do I do the stuff that I want to do and
like the middle the middle ground
between those two things and ideally
when you have the right sort of audience
and the right sort of content there's a
lot of overlap between those things yeah
like I know I'm like I've recently
bought this like just random typewriter
a smart typewriter which connects to
Wi-Fi and it's just a type all you can
do on it is right now this is something
I'm really excited about
and there is like a small segment of my
audience who will be as well but it's a
bit Niche like most people are not going
to care about that and I have to kind of
be okay with that so how do you decide
if you're going to make the video or not
my model is always that oh always a
strong word but like the model I aspire
to have is if I think this will be
helpful to at least one person then I
make the video and I don't care about
the views nice and I find that the less
I look at the numbers the happier I am
like for my last two videos I know
they're not doing amazingly and I
actually specifically have not looked at
YouTube studio and whenever I find
myself like itching to open it I'm like
you know what I don't need to know
because whether or not the video does
well
I'm glad I put it out because
did you know that this video is not
performing well how does that affect you
mentally do you still feel like you're
the worst person in the world and or how
do you feel about that I feel like oh
this is the beginning of the end I'm
fading into irrelevancy No One's Gonna
watch my videos I'm gonna become
homeless and broken alone yeah what's it
like for you I'm the exact same way I'm
like I so sometimes when a video is
performing really bad I'll call my mom
and I'll be like Mom I'm just gonna
start applying for jobs this is not
working out no one cares anymore and I
just kind of spiral and then I you know
try again next week as I post one video
a week and if two videos in a row are
not performing well that's what I'm like
okay my CV is like getting ready to be
sent out because this is not working
anymore and there's been so many times
like that but then you have a video
where it's going well again and so just
not quitting and being consistent
is so important because you're going to
want to quit like quit I think a lot of
times if you do this long enough
um but just keep going yeah
yeah I think the way I think of it is
um after loads of journaling definitely
want to talk to you about journaling
because you just read to skillshot class
about journaling yeah a bit more
generally
um but I I often Journal like whether
it's by hand or on computer and after
after several thousand words I arrive at
the conclusion of you know what I can
just make videos about what I want and
it's fine and right now it's working and
if it's if it ever stops working then
I'll just get it done I'll figure
something out yeah like the
the worst case scenario is not
catastrophic yeah so I think just
reminding yourself of that even if
because I think I mean you get so
comfortable I think you can relate to
this doing this job because it's you
have all the freedom and it's so
enjoyable and it's a dream like
sometimes I can't believe that I get to
do this like I can't believe I'm just
able to be here and this is part of my
job is chatting with you it doesn't feel
like
that should be a part of a job because
it's too enjoyable and so I think
there's always a fear of what if I lose
that and what if I go back to having to
do something that I don't enjoy and
that's scary but then again you can only
do your best and hope that people
continue to resonate and find you
interesting and valuable or what you
have to say interesting and valuable
yeah let's go with let's go away
just a quick message from one of our
sponsors and we'll get right back to the
episode and this episode is very kindly
brought to you by short form short form
is the world's best service that
summarizes books but it's way more than
just book summaries they almost have a
whole study guide for every book that
they've got on the platform where
they've got a one-page summary and then
they also have chapter by chapter
breakdowns and it's not just chapter by
chapter breakdowns also in between the
chapter breakdowns they have interactive
exercises where you can engage more
readily with the ideas in the book short
form covers non-fiction books from a
bunch of different genres that you might
be interested in for example they've got
a load of stuff in the business world so
if for example you're an entrepreneur or
you want to become an entrepreneur
that'll be great for you they've got
books in motivation they've got books in
education they've got books and
lifestyle and communication basically
any genre of like non-fiction personal
development is self-helpy stuff that
will help you level up your life it's
all there on short form short form
Publishers new book guides and articles
every week and if you're a subscriber
then you get to vote on what book they
cover next and in fact through that
system I have voted for various books
that they've then turned into summaries
for example I recently read the short
form guide to a book by Pat lindsione
called the five dysfunctions of a team
now this is a really good book itself I
listen to it on Audible I think last
year and it's like a fable about leading
and managing a team and it's like it's
really nice it's like in the form of a
story where there's guys like struggling
with his business and then he meets a
mentor and the mentor teaches him about
the five dysfunctions of a team but to
be honest once you've heard the story
once you kind of want to revisit the
five dysfunctions just the key lessons
without having to go through the story
because like the story is good the first
time around anyway thanks to short form
I was able to revisit the five key
lessons from that book in the space of
about a minute rather than having to
reread the thing which would have taken
several hours anyway if any of that
sounds up your street and you would like
to sign up to the world's best service
that summarizes books then head over to
shortform.com forward slash deep dive
and that will give you a completely free
five-day trial and you can try out the
service to your heart's content that
link will also be in the video
description and in the show notes and
thank you so much short form for
sponsoring this episode just a quick
little break and we'll get right back to
the podcast shortly but this is to let
you know that this podcast is very
kindly brought to you by paypalike
paperlike is by far the best screen
protector for the iPad that is on the
market I've been using the paper-like
screen protector since like 2018 when I
first got the iPad Pro and they have had
various evolutions and stuff since then
but the most recent version is the paper
like 2.1 otherwise known as The Swiss
paper-like and it's really good it
basically makes writing on the iPad with
an apple pencil feel like writing on
paper but to be honest the paper-like
screen protector has been doing that
since 2018. what's different about this
new paperlike 2.1 is that the Nano dots
which are the little bits on the screen
that make it feel that friction
resistance as if you're writing on paper
those are spaced more widely apart and
so you get exactly the same kind of
feeling of writing on paper but you get
a lot less refraction of the screen and
so like having a screen protector on on
the iPad it's almost not noticeable that
there is a screen protector on the iPad
whereas In fairness with previous
versions of the paper-like and other
screen protectors on the market you do
genuinely get this like refractiony type
thing that makes look a bit crap but I'm
so glad that they've got this new
version 2.1 out because now like the
absolutely marvelous iPad screen is not
being adulterated by the screen
protector on it anyway if you have an
iPad or an iPad Air or an iPad Pro then
you definitely want to get a paper-like
screen protector for it assuming you
right with the apple pencil and you can
do that by heading over to paperlike.com
forward slash Deep dive or by hitting
the link in the video description or in
the show notes so thank you so much
paperlike for sponsoring this episode
and let's get right back to the show
you talk a lot about so your video that
went viral was I think a day in the life
of an introvert yeah
um
to what extent do you identify as an
introvert like what does introvert beam
mean to you
so
I've kind of tried to not identify too
much with any term recently just because
I feel like
it boxes you win somehow so I know that
I would talk a lot about being
introverted and you know having these
traits and whatnot and it will get to a
point where if I were to post like a
story on Instagram having dinner with
friends I would get the answer of people
being like I thought you were an
introvert who doesn't like going out so
why are you out with friends and I got
me thinking like this is
like it's getting to a point where not
only am I boxing myself in but other or
boxing man as well and I think that can
be the danger of self-labeling you feel
like okay I have this label I am this or
that so I should act in this way and I
just don't really want to have that in
my life I want to feel like even if I
feel yeah I'm introverted because I like
my alone time and I don't need to be
with people as much as some other people
might need to be with people and but
that does not mean that I don't enjoy
other people or that I don't want to go
out and do this and that so
I just try to stay clear of boxing
myself in as much as possible
um but I still do make some content
about introversion because I know that
learning about it helped me so much and
just being like Oh I'm not this weird
person because I could spend the entire
day at home and just doing my own stuff
it's just because that's how I enjoy
being and that's completely fine and it
is very helpful to so many people just
learning about it and talking about it
so I still do it but I don't say I am an
introvert I'm like I'm introverted
because like it's spectrum and no one is
only that or only that we're all
somewhere in the middle of these terms
and definitions I think what do you
think I feel like you're extroverted
or hmm
I would say I'm more introverted I I
assuming the definition is around sort
of getting your energy by recharging
with your own company versus other
people so like for example if I'm if
often if I'm on holiday with friends I
will enjoy taking out a few hours in the
morning to just sit on my laptop and do
some work maybe that's just the
workaholic partner
yeah I feel like a lot of social contact
is a bit much and I like just having
time on my laptop or with the journal
where I can just do my own thing
um last week I I interviewed someone
called Francesca Specter who's a
journalist who's written a book called
uh uh alone mint which is about this
sort of
um spending time by yourself and using
that to recharge and like being okay
with that I really like that term it's
like a nice
so the the day I interviewed her that
evening I went to a restaurant by myself
and just did some journaling nice went
on a date with myself and it was like oh
this is so nice do you ever do that
normally going out eating by yourself
not usually I think I've done it like
twice in the last year one time was last
week it was great I want to do more of
that and even like well one of her tips
was to block it out in the calendar
because then you can look forward to it
whereas normally if I have a random
spare evening I'll just sort of
non-intentionally do something but in
this case it's like oh today is going to
be an alignment evening I'm gonna spend
time by myself and it's going to be
great and I think it's important because
you get to be alone with because when
you're around people
I mean sure you can be yourself but it's
inevitable that you're getting
influenced by other people's moods and
thoughts and experiences and what
they're saying and what they're thinking
and all of that whereas when you're by
yourself you get to kind of fully and
truly
listen to your own thoughts and be like
what do I think about this thing and how
do I enjoy this food or this place or
whatever it is that you're doing and I
think it's valuable and kind of getting
to know yourself
anyway but how do you feel working with
a big team and meeting them every day
and because I feel like now that I'm
doing everything by myself and imagining
having a team of a lot of people that I
not have to spend every day with but
that I will spend every day with it
feels a little bit draining how do you
feel about that do you feel energized
when you're around
generally yeah generally I do
um so usually my setup is that my
mornings are for book writing so like
this morning had breakfast with my agent
and then sort of nine till 12 was book
time sitting in a coffee shop and just
doing book stuff and then I came here
and now we're having this chat and I had
a team meeting just a little while ago
and doing like a working dinner tonight
as well with with with Tommy and I find
that that balance where it's like I've
got some of the day to do my own deep
work and the rest of the time I can just
sort of have Good Vibes with the team I
really enjoy that and I like working
with people around because I get a bit
depressed when it's just me and I'm
sitting on my laptop all day oh really
do you find that or do you enjoy sitting
on your laptop
yeah but I mean I thought because I
haven't I don't know what the opposite
would be like either so I don't know if
I were to have a team
being around people working I don't know
if I would join maybe I would but I
think you would I haven't tried it so
imagine how sick it would be if you had
like one or two people yeah that you
worked with maybe like a couple of days
a week you would go to the same coffee
shop or the same co-working school I
think so I think if it's the right
people where you have good chemistry and
which I think is so important I mean
I've tried having people on my team like
an editor or like the very basic
thing that YouTubers typically need help
with but I think it's so hard just
I don't know like going from doing
everything by yourself you know all the
different roles of being a YouTuber
entails to bringing someone in
I feel like it's such a scary thing I
don't know how you've successfully found
so many people and they all seem great
yeah how do you
just that process seems so yeah I mean
it sort of happened slowly over a long
period so it's been like sort of um
started working with Christian or editor
three years ago now okay and so in the
early days he was like sending me the
final cut so sending me the project
files and I was doing the Final Cut of
editing myself and then after a while I
was like oh he's actually better than I
am cool and then now we just do it via
frame IO where he just uploads a file
and then I can leave comments on it and
then and then it goes to the channel
nice and it's just like I remember in
the early days the feeling I had when
I'd be excited I'd be filming a video in
the evening after work and then I'd go
to work the next day and then I'd come
home and the video is ready and I'm just
like mind blown like I didn't have to
spend 18 hours editing this video and
that just completely changed my life
yeah and as soon as Christian came on
board suddenly everything started going
well in the business and because I had
way more time to spend on actually
writing the videos and writing courses
which is the thing I enjoy doing rather
than
I'm cutting out my arms and ours and do
you do any editing no
well no nice I sometimes think you know
what I should go back into editing
yeah
how long it takes yeah and then I think
huh this is like
would I choose to do this just for fun
right and if the answer is no then it's
like okay then I shouldn't be doing this
oh okay whereas I would choose to write
just for fun or to read just for fun but
I wouldn't choose to edit just for fun
you have written and talked a lot about
the concept of row yeah what is row so
pronounced in Swedish it's just another
word I don't think anyone really thinks
about it more than any other word but
it's a word that doesn't have
um direct translation to any other
language that I know of at least not
English basically what it means
rule is just like calm Tranquility peace
um so if you've had like a long day you
might say in Swedish
I
just want some peace and calm or
I want to find a place to have some rule
um
and I started because
a lot of
but somehow my philosophy in life is
goes back to rule essentially means that
even at the end of the day if I've had a
long day or stressful day I always want
to feel like I'm coming back to a place
where I feel like I can rest and relax
and feel it calm
on the inside and I try to create those
habits
in my everyday life I want my home to be
that place I want to have that feeling
with my close relationships where I can
feel like this person
gives me some rule as opposed to the
opposite of giving me stress or anxiety
or
um
yeah so I think that's just where it
started I was like this is a great word
and more people should know of this word
or concept and I started my newsletter
named it Monday Monday I think I haven't
been writing a lot there but um
basically just writing
stories of rule or tips on Rue and
things like that and a lot of people
enjoyed it and resonated with the
concept of just wanting more through in
their lives and that's how that was born
yeah
um how how does one go about finding
um good good pronunciation
um
give me different things to different
people so like having a rule in the
morning to me is just
not feeling stressed in the morning and
waking up early enough to where I can
have a coffee and sit on my couch and
cuddle my dog and not have to hurry
anywhere or feel like I'm
stressed out and that I'm well breasted
so that's just a way if I need it or I
love taking long walks and not listening
to anything and just enjoying the walk
with no sounds and to me that's true so
I think
it means different things to different
people but I think the feeling is just
simply
it's a bit meditative where it's like
it's like the feeling where you're
taking a long walk in the forest or
something and you don't have any
distractions other than bird sounds or
you know the sound of bushes or whatever
something that is just very peaceful and
calming and
yeah I think it's going to be different
things for different people but you're
gonna know if you start paying attention
to your day like where do I feel like
I'm
at ease where do I feel like no one is
bothering me there's like a calm feeling
throughout my body and I'm just being
and
what is that to you can you identify
anything like that in your life yeah
yeah very much so I was just thinking as
you were saying that that like your
whole vibe is very like Rue how nice
very like kind of Zen kind of like calm
and try and quill and
it's just a sort of just like sitting
here talking to you is making me just
feel a bit more calm I'm just like yeah
this is falling asleep I had a nice
conversation I feel like I'm relaxed I
feel like I'm I'm energized and well it
was sort of like uh being energized
through being relaxed yeah rather than
being energized through being like
frantic almost yeah so it's not
necessarily to me it's not like feeling
sleepy or you know taking a nap it is
feeling energized but through something
very simple and calming so journaling
can be pretty
pretty much that as well depending on
what you're writing about that you're
ranting about a recent heartbreak maybe
it's not very robots
can you find anything specific in yeah
so I've been thinking about this sort of
concept A Lot recently
um because with the book that I'm
working on
um
the core thesis I guess is that
you know for me productivity has always
been about trying to trying to get
energy from my work so that I can give
energy to the things that I want to do
outside of work and I find that the way
I get energy from my work is by
approaching it in this sort of
with lightness and ease and tranquility
and remembering to have fun with it and
remembering that I don't need to be
stressed out and I think it's it's easy
to
and even if you even had this one when I
wasn't working for myself so when I was
working as a doctor it's it's very easy
to sort of approach it with a frantic
energy of like oh [ __ ] all this [ __ ]
needs to be done and stuff
yeah
um and I found that on days where I
would have that attitude towards it I
would just feel completely drained and
it wasn't fun
but on days where I had exactly the same
to-do list but I approached it with a
sense of
I've got a lot of things to do today
this is going to be fun yeah
um there's a there's a quote from Gray's
Anatomy where um Patrick Dempsey the
neurosurgeon he always starts his
operations with uh it's a beautiful day
to save lives let's have some fun nice
and I sometimes think about that as
being like that is actually a way of
approaching anything it's a beautiful
day to save lives let's have some fun
regardless of what's actually happening
in the thing and so I try and remind
myself to do that with with work staff
or whenever I feel
frantic or harried in any kind of way
yeah just taking that breath
I mean like no it's all good and I can
choose to approach this with I guess
root rather than yeah totally I think I
think attitude is like I know some
people get annoyed when you talk about
just have a positive attitude or a good
attitude but I really think that it
does so much to how you approach things
and how you see things like if I think
to myself okay I have to create this
video this week and I have to do this
and that and I kind of stress myself up
of all the things that I have to do and
accomplish and the time that I have
doing it and deadlines I'm just going to
be stressed out I'm not going to enjoy
the process as much and it's probably
not going to turn out as well either
because it's going to start feeling like
this thing that I just have to do rather
than this thing that I want to do
if I Instead try to be like okay I have
to write the script I'm gonna grab my
coffee I'm gonna sit on the couch I'm
gonna put my dog in my lap and we're
gonna go about this and
somehow we feel like if we have more of
a calm approach to things we're not as
productive you know it's not as
efficient you kind of
I can at least feel sometimes like okay
why am I not feeling
too stressed about this does that mean
that I'm slacking even if I'm getting as
much done and getting it done better
than I would have otherwise there's
something
and me and maybe you and other people
where you kind of feel like being
productive means that you need to feel
like you're running around and you're
doing this and that and you're switching
between tasks and you're like you want
to feel a little bit stressed that can
sometimes make you feel like you're
being more productive whereas if you're
drinking coffee and you're just kind of
having this calm Vibe you might feel
like you're not being as productive even
if you are so I'm just trying to lean
into the fact that I can actually
approach things
be more
chill with that Gray's Anatomy quote
attitude and I can still heal the same
results and enjoy the process a lot more
yeah have you come across uh Derek
sivers I don't think so he's like this
uh you know he used to be an
entrepreneur I sold his money as a sold
his company for a lot of money and then
decided to live the chill life of kind
of doing what he wants and he's he's
written a couple of really good books
about like like intentional living and
stuff
um but there's a really good story that
he talks about of how you know he I
think he used to live in like Australia
or something and he used to sort of
cycle the length of some psychopath and
he would always try and like go as fast
as possible and he'd be like okay you
need to beat 42 minutes need to be 42
minutes and 42 minutes was his number
um and then one day he decided you know
what I'm just gonna take a chill like
I'm actually good I'm not going to huff
and puff I'm gonna enjoy and I'm gonna
enjoy the cycle ride as I'm going along
and you know he was like I'm not going
to turn myself I'm just going to go
around the cycle you know I'm gonna um
might like wavered some people along the
way listen to the birds I really enjoy
myself and he gets back home and he
looks at his clock and it's 44 minutes
and he's like [ __ ] well for the last
like six months have I just been huffing
and puffing for the sake of two minutes
like what the [ __ ] and now he like I
think there's a a wider message in that
yeah
huffing and puffing actually does not
necessarily lead to the outcome that you
think it's going to get to exactly I
think that's exactly what I mean yeah or
what I'm trying to say huffing and
puffing exactly I haven't heard of that
but yeah I guess that's what I'm trying
to say where I think that example is
great and that's I'm just trying to
embrace more of that nice
so someone listening to this might be
like well Lana and Ali it's easy for you
guys to say you guys are YouTubers you
make videos about what you want like uh
screw you like I've got a real job
um yeah given that you've you've written
a lot written a lot about this how if
let's say someone has a real job maybe
potentially has like family obligations
plus or minus kids at home
um any tips on finding roof in the midst
of a hectic life right
um so I'm not even gonna try and put
myself in the position of someone having
kids and a family and all of that I know
that when I started YouTube and I was
working as well and I was
doing both the thing that gave me rule
which I was doing every single morning
before going to work was actually
working out at a quiet gym where no one
was because it was very early
so
somehow was a sacrifice because I was
getting up very early
um and maybe not getting enough sleep
but that was a way for me back then to
have some time to myself where I wasn't
working on anything and I was just doing
something that was good for me and I
felt energized but
I it was in frantic it was just
me alone at the gym working out and so I
think
I think you can
find little things that you can do but
maybe there's another sacrifice that has
to be done like maybe you have to set
your alarm
a little bit earlier or maybe at your
lunch break okay go to your car and eat
it there if you want to get get away
from some people I know that I would do
that sometimes and just not to my car
but just leave everyone and go have
lunch by myself just any opportunity
that you can find where you can spend
that time
away from the crowd and away from the
noise whether that is when you're having
lunch or your coffee or waking up
earlier and working out or journaling a
little bit before you go to bed I think
we can find those moments they don't
have to be long moments they can be a
couple minutes like go to your balcony
if you have one and stand there with no
devices for a couple minutes and just
take a few breaths like something as
simple as that I think can do more than
we think and most people probably have
two minutes
some sometime throughout the day to just
go away from the crowd and take a
breather yeah yeah I would hope yeah
yeah I was interviewing someone last
week who's a psychiatrist and
neuroscientist and we were talking about
a similar concept as well
um
uh from a sort of sciency perspective
it's kind of resetting the nervous
system
um where you've got the sympathetic
nervous system which is your fight or
flight response the anxiety the stress
the sort of this is useful if you're
running away from a lion
and then you have the parasympathetic
nervous system which is where your
chilled sort of rest digest recharge
that kind of vibe and how he you know
she cited some study that showed that
like 75 of workers in the US are in sort
of sympathetic overdrive mode where
they're like in this state of mild
anxiety and stress in their workday and
how
is it really bad for your health drives
up your cortisol level increases your
blood pressure all these all these bad
things and something like something as
simple as looking into the into the
distance like into the Horizon and
taking some deep breaths for like 30
seconds just tells your body no it's
chill I don't have a tiger that's
chasing me right now it's just my boss
being a bit of a dick like yeah I don't
need to let this affect my tranquility
and even just 30 seconds can profoundly
recharge someone's energy levels
absolutely and there's a bunch of stuff
that shows that you know taking a break
every 45 minutes and even just like
getting off your desk and just taking a
few deep breaths just lets your body
relax and the more relaxed the more
parasympathetically you can kind of
activate yourself the more likely you
are to recharge your energy and to feel
more of that sense of peace and peace
and Stillness and Tranquility this idea
of I guess yeah I think just not forcing
yourself to be in a situation if you
feel like you need a couple minutes like
um I know in the beginning when I was
working my nine to five I thought it was
very weird like going away during lunch
just to have a couple minutes to myself
because are people gonna think like
where's Lana why is she leaving and
something is off but no one really cares
I don't think no one is gonna question
you or think you're a weirdo if you just
go away for a few minutes or decide to
have a lunch by yourself or
if you're having a break and someone's
like hey do you want to take a walk
together if you want to go alone once in
a while like that's fine and I think we
should just Embrace those moments and no
one's actually gonna care that much and
it's important to grab those moments
when we need them and when we have the
opportunity
like so um again when I was when I was
working as a doctor
um in the early days
me and most of my friends who started
around that time it's like it was super
super stressful they were like oh
there's too much to do and there's so
much to do that we can't take a lunch
break because like there's just
literally too much to do and like you
know can't stop for coffee you just have
to keep going because all these things
are Urgent all these things are
happening and then very quickly our
seniors told us that no you need to take
a lunch break you need to take coffee
breaks nothing bad will happen don't
worry about it yeah and we started doing
that and realized that actually taking a
coffee break like two or three times it
going down to the local Costa waiting in
line for five minutes getting a latte
and going back up just takes like takes
away five or ten minutes and you know
there's very unlikely to be a life or
death emergency in that five or ten
minutes and if it is the crash buzzer is
going to ring and someone else will be
there but you can take that time totally
and if that tight that five or ten
minutes returns so much Roi because it
just helps you avoid burnout and feel
more confident and tranquil and
comfortable at work and stuff and all
and that has so many more benefits
compared to thinking that you have to I
guess burn the afterburners and skip
lunch just for the sake of writing an
extra discharge letter a little bit
earlier totally and I think let's say
there was an emergency you're probably
going to be have a better be in a better
mind space if you've taken a couple
minutes off where you kind of recharge a
little bit as opposed to if you've just
been going and going going all day
you're probably going to be more tired
and exhausted so I think that applies
for work as well if you're just going
and going and going without break
because you feel like you can't or you
feel guilty or you need to be super
productive and breaks are for lazy
people or whatever you're telling
yourself I think you're just doing the
opposite you're burning yourself out and
you're not going to be as effective and
maybe most importantly you're not going
to enjoy yourself as much you're just
going to feel exhausted and if you're
not enjoying what you're doing the
results are probably not going to be as
good as if you were enjoying what you're
doing yeah yeah and there's a lot like I
think the Happiness Advantage that talks
about how people who feel happy at work
also perform way better and it's not the
other way around it's not that
performance leads to happiness it's that
happiness leads to Performance and so if
we can find ways to feel happier feel
more content with the work that we're
doing inevitably that's going to lead to
performance improvements but also we're
having a better lifestyle yeah why why
wouldn't why don't you try it because
you're spending so much time in work
like so much of your life
is working and so finding any
loophole or tactic or anything to make
it a bit easier and more enjoyable I
think it's at least worth exploring
yeah what what kind of stuff do you find
disturbs your Tranquility on a
day-to-day basis
I think mainly
if something is off in any of my
relationships
like if I've had a fight with someone or
someone is mad at me or anything like
that I think that's the biggest thing
nothing else really
gets to me as much as things not going
well or smoothly in my relationships I
think that's the thing
what do you do about it when you find
that that's the case
um
well I try to
I try for it to not get to the extent
where something is
you know there's an argument I try to
solve things as quickly as possible
that's something I've learned
throughout the years instead of kind of
um
leaving things be and I think it's
better to talk about things and try to
be on a
try to try to have peace in your
relationships if something is bothering
me or bothering them I always try to
solve it as quickly as possible and if
it's unsolvable
I'm still working on trying to still go
about my day and not I just get very
affected by like things being off with
the people around me and do you do you
experience that
'll like if you've had a fight with
your brother or I don't know someone do
you feel like it's affecting your work
or how you're feeling about your day
I'm not ready
um so I I tend not to have that many
fights except with my mom
um well let's say you've had a fight
with your mom yeah do you feel like your
day is not ruined but like you're not
going to be as
excited or
no really I feel like I'm pretty good at
compartmentalizing and also
I think the stoicism Kool-Aid I've been
drinking for decades tells me that is is
this within my control no okay I can
just choose to think to be okay with it
then well how do you get to a point
where you actually believe that like
I think I got to that point by telling
myself that repeatedly over many years
and to the point where it's now like
because I I strongly think I strongly
feel that we can control our feelings uh
maybe we can't control that initial you
know that initial gut level reaction
but you know there's a bunch of stuff
about how emotions are renewed every 90
seconds and if you feel anger anger will
only last for 90 seconds
and then if it lasts for longer than
that it's because you're choosing to
tell yourself a story that's causing The
Amity renewed oh yeah those I can't
remember what book is but there's
there's something I would love to read
more I'm putting uh kind of stats on
this
and similarly you know a book like the
courage to be disliked or any of the
books on stoicism talk about this idea
of you know you've got stimulus and
response and in between those two
there's a gap and you can choose your
response and so if I have had a fight
with my mum or if I don't know
something is not worked out with another
relationship
I can choose the way I respond to that
to an extent like I've been lucky in
that I haven't had like a major like
absolute catastrophic thing happen yeah
but I think over time with with the
little things in particular I've become
good at
being like Yep this is a thing my
initial response is anger or frustration
or upsetness or whatever
cool that's fine I I can choose to tell
myself a different story that that means
that
I can I you know that the the quote
which is
um pain is inevitable but suffering is
optional yeah so I've experienced the
pain of the initial emotion but I can
choose to not suffer hmm and how
seamless is that for you is it always
obvious that you can just think that and
believe it or is it harder sometimes
yeah it's harder sometimes
um yeah like yesterday
you know I had a bit of a disagreement
with my girlfriend about some something
and
I was feeling a bit like I was feeling a
bit frustrated a bit annoyed and was
like okay no you know take a few deep
breaths
figure out how I feel about this and
then we had we had a conversation about
it and after about 20 minutes of
conversation turns out it was a
misunderstanding where we both like
we're on a different page about the same
thing and it's like okay now we resolve
the misunderstanding and we kind of
talked about it and I was like great
this is awesome and so but but I did
feel that initial sense of like
annoyance and frustration and I was like
okay
deep breath that's fine let's have a
rational conversation yeah but I think
that's the key having a conversation
about it I think if you were to
go to bed and or if you were not with
her at the time let's say you were not
able to see her or yeah talk to her
then do you feel like that could affect
your like if that was unresolved until
right now yeah you feel like your work
day would have been like would you have
thought about it or can you just put it
to the side and get to work I wouldn't
thought about it
um I would I would have I would tell
myself I can put it to the side and
forget about it and deal with it later
but I would it would sort of be in the
back of my mind
um until we have our regular
relationship review where we kind of go
through some questions and what is that
oh it's great this is a thing I've been
yeah I've been recommending this to all
my friends I'm like can we switch gears
because I like to hear about this
um so this is an idea from Logan Yuri's
book how to not die alone which is you
know behavioral scientists turned
relationship coach um which is over
there actually uh and yeah she says
basically that
anyone in a relationship should have
like a weekly ish review
um we do ask like every every three
weeks or so because we don't see each
other that often maybe like once or
twice a week so every three weeks or so
we'll do a review where there's like a
notion page with like 10 questions and
we just go through the questions and
that's very are we having that on notion
yeah although it was it was her who
actually made the notion page initially
so it was like yeah that's when I knew
she was the one oh nice
um and we just go through the questions
and you know the first half are like
um you know how's how's this week been
for our relationship what's something
you know how are you feeling what's
something I did that made you feel loved
or appreciated or supported
um what's something you'd like to do
more of together and then it's like you
know what's one way what's one thing I
did that made you feel bad or sad or
annoyed in any kind of way how can make
it better what can it do differently and
usually you know through answering these
questions it's just a good chance to ask
meta level questions about the
relationship that wouldn't otherwise
come up in day-to-day life yeah and so
generally if she or I of like a thing
because I feel like the the problem in
relationships from a bit of experience
and from what I've read is that the
little things can become big things over
time yeah and a little thing is often
too little to bring up in the moment
especially when you're apart like when
they're at work it's like I'm not gonna
message be like hey you know that little
thing that you said that right it would
just be a bit weird to do that because
it just interrupts things
and so the review gives a chance for
like every couple of weeks at least a
chance to review and touch base on those
things and the benefit is that usually a
week is elapse between the event
happening and the review so then you can
approach it with less of an emotional
kind of Spin and more like hey so when
you did X it made me feel why and you
know just to let you know and I'm
usually like oh my God I had no idea
like you know let's change that and does
it usually feel
because it sounds a little bit like a
not a venting session but a little bit
like you're kind of venting on things
that maybe you've thought of or things
that you want to get out there do you
feel like do the both of you feel better
in like at ease after you oh yeah
definitely like we often say afterwards
like oh I'm glad we did this review or
like sometimes we'll say but like oh if
it feels like it's been a while since
we've done a review we should probably
do one whereas like maybe there's like
one or two small things that have sort
of sort of like are in the background
and are too small to bring up and so the
review brings them to light
and
yeah I think it's been one of the one of
the things that's taught me the most
over the last year of being in the
relationship that oh damn I didn't
realize that people have emotions I
didn't realize that like you would think
of things in this way but it makes sense
now that you've explained it and so I
can weave that into my mental model of
the world okay yeah and do you feel like
since you're having this review with her
do you feel like you're kind of saving
things that you might be like things
that might be bothering you or that
you're thinking about or do you still
bring those things up as well or do you
guys save it to the review yeah how do
you go about that that's a good question
so sometimes like if we're there in the
moment then then I'll bring it up but I
generally prefer to have this the
conversation in person rather than on
the phone so if for example we're not
seeing each other for a week or two then
to me I I'd be thinking okay is this
something worth bringing up over the
phone or over WhatsApp probably not I'll
just save it to the review but if it's
something big then we'll bring it up
over the phone if necessary
yeah it's almost like like you know
having a one-on-one when you have like
employees and stuff a one-on-one with a
manager yeah where a lot of things you
can just say for the one-on-one because
you don't have to interrupt them and
send them a message on slack to be like
hey let's talk about this thing you can
be like oh you know it's it's a thing
that we can talk about in the next
one-on-one yeah unless it's sufficiently
baked an immediate discussion okay
yeah because I remember uh friend's
colleague told me that
his boss and his boss's wife would do
something similar where every week or
every two weeks they would sit down and
I don't know if it was from this book or
if it was like a set of questions but
they would just talk openly about I hope
you felt about the relationship this
weekend is something on your mind you
want to talk about anything in
particular and how have you felt
appreciated and how can we make things
better having that conversation yeah I
would recommend it okay cool
um well carry that with me yeah so you
you put out a couple of videos recently
talking about like your experiences of
dating your experience of relationships
um I guess let's start with dick with
dating
um what have you learned from kind of
dating life over the last however number
of years wow
[Music]
um
and I guess if you were giving advice to
your younger self who's like let's say
someone's listening to this and they're
recently single they've been in a
relationship for a while but now they're
like single and they're on the market
again as it were and they've got the
they're like oh hinge tender but I'm
like oh God feels like a real faff like
and I guess from your perspective as a
girl presumably you'll get loads of
matches and loads of people are weird
like what what what's that like
I'm getting a lot of matches just like
being a girl on a dating app
um which by definition means getting a
lot of messages from from every other
girls dating apps that I've ever seen
um
I think
well there is
definitely something to it I mean
everyone knows I think that women tend
to get more matches than men but I think
it gets confused with you know Allah
does not mean you know good right so you
could be let's give an example like you
could be getting a lot of um cookies but
maybe half of them are too old to eat
and yeah moldy and they're breaking and
there was a warm in one and you don't
want to have that one so it doesn't
matter that you're getting a lot of
cookies if none of them are worth eating
do you know what I mean so I think it's
something
you think quantity and quality is like
quality is getting
confused for Quality like let's say
you're getting I don't know let's throw
out a number you're getting 20 matches
this week
um which may be a lot or a little
depending on how you see it I don't know
um sounds like a lot
I mean that all 20 are
eligible for you or that that's
something that you could see yourself
being with or spending your life with or
whatever you're looking for but I guess
it does it does mean you have more
options yeah so of those 20 even if like
10 are reasonable definitely then yeah I
think in that way but I think
I mean I don't know what it's like
obviously being a guy on a dating app
I've talked to some guys on dating apps
so that also depends I mean
women are pickier yeah that's that's the
fact
um
and I mean both women and men I think
have the right to be picky I don't think
that's a that's a problem
um as long as it's realistic and you
don't have your standards
come from like a row Rome rom-com or
anything like that
um
but yeah what is like dating I think
dating in today's climate is difficult
for everyone because
a lot of it is online we don't I don't
think we need as often as maybe we used
to people in person unless you're in
school or maybe through work and now so
many people are working from home and so
I think naturally a lot of people are
drawn to
dating apps which is kind of unnatural
because normally when you meet someone
um it's you know it's obviously the
looks and how you feel about the person
but it's also like how their energy is
feeling and their voice and their eye
contact and
their scent and all of these things play
a role in how we feel about someone when
we meet them organically in person and
you have none of that when you meet
someone online so it's it's tough and so
you just go based on pictures
um and some information on their profile
and an exchange of conversation that you
have or a call I always recommend having
a call before meeting someone oh yeah do
you normally suggest that yeah always
really video call video call Dad yeah
how do people respond uh they're like
yeah sure yeah no one's been resistant
yeah
have you never done that
um I did it like over the kind of
lockdown period I went on a few Zoom
dates and I don't particularly enjoy any
of them but like yeah someone else did
tell me that like we it like that if you
have
too many options like if you're if it's
not a supply problem that you're dealing
with then a call is a really helpful way
of just like eliminating just a very
easy and quick and painless way to
eliminate people from from the list yeah
because you can just immediately check
do you Vibe over FaceTime exactly and if
you don't or if they don't have an
iPhone then it's like exactly apart from
the list immediately
um I think it's two things so I think
first thing when you said like okay are
we clicking at all or is it just like do
I know right from the back that this is
not going anywhere and also I think
um maybe particularly as a woman just
making sure it's someone who isn't like
weird or that feels you know I don't
know dangerous or uh anything like that
and four men as well something can be
like a catfish but
yeah I think it's always good to have a
video call with someone okay yeah
what are some other
uh I guess things that you've learned
over the years the kind of tips that you
share with people so I guess one of them
is have a video call yeah anything else
that
um
giving people a chance I think we're
very quick sometimes when we go on a
date with someone being like oh they're
wearing the wrong shoes or
um they said something that didn't fully
align with something that I believe in
and we might eliminate them for these
reasons that
may be something that is not
um like shouldn't be a determining
Factor if you want to like have a
serious relationship with someone if
you're just looking for something casual
yeah maybe you're more shallow because
you know I don't know something like
that but if you're looking for something
long-term I think not overlooking
someone completely just because
something is not fully
resonate with you or
um because they seem to be different
from you in some way like most things
like it could probably work despite them
being
um in some ways yeah because we all have
things that are like someone's gonna be
like oh you do that that's kind of
strange I don't do that yeah and just
being if you're a YouTuber for example
people are just like what the hell
that's a bit weird it is a bit weird to
some people and some people get scared I
don't know that's what does that mean
um so I think just giving people more of
a chance but not
not to the extent where you see someone
for a month and you're not feeling it
right because then it's like okay you've
been seeing this person for a month
you've gone on I don't know eight dates
and there is
nothing happening in your body you're
not excited you look into their eyes and
there's nothing drawing you in then it's
probably not your person
um so somewhere between one date and
eight dates yeah well eight things is
kind of a lot and that's not I learned
her her rule is the two-day rule which
is that always go on the second date
unless there's like a major red flag on
the first and then you can decide after
the second date oh because normally
people are a bit weird on the first day
anyway it's a bit unusual and often
uncomfortable yeah and the second date
gives another shot again assuming
there's no like massive red flags yeah I
think so I think that's reasonable
unless
unless you meet them and you just really
are not interested at all like you don't
even want to listen to them talk because
there's just no chemistry then maybe not
a second date but I think that's
generally good advice like if you're
like this like if it's a maybe I think
that's good enough
I don't really buy this whole thing it
has to be a hell yes from the beginning
because like does that happen a lot to
people I have a hard time believing
majority of people are like Oh Yeah from
like the moment I saw this person it was
just perfect and I knew I think most
people land somewhere in between
yeah it was okay like I was willing to
see this person again I think it's okay
to expect that and not expect
fireworks and you know having a jungle
doing and jumping up and down in your
stomach the first time you see them I
don't think that has to be necessary
what do you think yeah no I agree I'm
I'm very uh what do you think you need
to feel do you think you need to feel
all the butterflies and everything like
the first time you
season one yeah no probably not
um I'm thinking yeah this is the this is
the thing I've always kind of
had had in my mind as a question mark of
like how long do you give it because if
I think of people who I like who I had a
crush on at like University
if it wasn't someone I was immediately
attracted to from day one then it took
like months to years of getting to know
them to be like oh hang on like we get
on really well like oh wow actually it's
kind of cool you know that kind of vibe
and it wouldn't have happened within
like one two or three dates in that in
that case yeah and so at one point I had
a three-day rule in my mind of like like
maybe my standards are too high maybe
I'm just like I'm just doing this wrong
I'm gonna always go on at least three
dates uh assuming the other person is
down for it and then I did this once or
twice and I was like no I I like to do
two or three times I was like I mean I
kind of knew from date number one that
we weren't going to get on but I just
forced myself to go on the rest which
seemed a bit unfair in hindsight and so
it's like I was always a bit unsure as
to
how do you know whether it's
just like dead in the water completely
or if it's like a maybe and I think that
was sort of where I landed on of like
if I'm at least a maybe then it's worth
going on the second day yeah
um with my current Google with my
current girlfriend it was fortunate that
it was a hell yeah from day one and so I
didn't I didn't have that issue to deal
with
um and it was really the first time that
I dated someone in a long time where I
was looking forward to the second day
because previously what I always had was
like
[Music]
but yeah okay well so you have that hell
yeah I had the hell yeah yeah
um nice which makes me a bit suspicious
because I'm like oh damn I I wish like a
rule had come to fruition and then I
could have been like the Rule's really
good yeah exactly alrighty so we were
talking about dating
um what advice would you have for guys
who are dating like do's and don'ts what
yeah what do guys need to know
in your view when it comes to dating
um well I feel like
it's not a lot of guys's favorite thing
when a woman gives
dating advice
somehow when I do this and I like try to
give advice to men some people get
upset saying I don't know yeah like how
dare I okay so in that case from from
your perspective what have been some
things that guys have done that have
like turned you off or like have been
particularly good
um okay so from my perspective yes
exactly it's purely from my perspective
yeah
um
honestly things like basic hygiene
what does basically do this
brush teeth
smelling nice
clothes that look like you cared at all
to come on this date
um because some people like will think
it's happened that someone comes and
I don't know it doesn't look like they
care because usually like if I go on a
date I will you know I'll care and I'll
just up and I'll fix my hair and so you
kind of want to feel like the other
person is meeting your effort okay
um so if they broke up and just like
tracksuit bottoms with like as if
looking as if they've just come from the
gym then unless you're into it maybe
like some people are some so that's why
it's so hard speaking in general terms
but personally I want to feel like I
mean you don't have to wear a suit
that's not what I'm talking about you
can wear jeans and a t-shirt but have it
look
intentionally I think that's like a
crumbly t-shirt at least maybe trying to
own it exactly like you want to feel
like this person
put some effort in okay because it makes
you feel like
because it's kind of like the halo
effect right where you feel like okay
they put effort into this so there's
someone who cares and they put effort
into other things whereas if someone
shows up and they haven't cared at all
at least it doesn't look like they cared
at all you kind of start thinking oh
there's someone who is just careless and
they you know you start applying it to
so many other areas which not may not
even be true but if you don't know you
can only go off of your first impression
so I think basic hygiene okay um
anything else
um
yes being interested
I think it's important
it's definitely it's
I've had experience where someone
where you get the impression they just
wanted someone to rant to kind of okay
and that's not very pleasant I mean you
want it to be a mutual exchange of
getting to know each other where you're
asking questions and they're asking
questions
um
and I know a lot of people struggle with
this but I think eye contact is
important because I think the eyes when
you're going on a date with someone is
they say so much to partly where you're
feeling about the person does it feel
like there could be you know a romance
there or does this feel very platonic
so I think if you're struggling with eye
contact try to practice eye contact not
like you don't have to stare at
someone's eyes but giving them the
chance to see what it feels like to look
inside your eyes and I think it just
creates more of a connection
so that's why I think if you're going on
a walk even just looking over at the
person instead of just walking straight
ahead without looking at them at all it
makes you appear less engaging in my
experience with a person and you want
them to feel engaged with you
um and then I think as cliche as it
sounds being yourself you know not
trying to present obviously put your
best foot forward
um but also don't try to present a
perfect version of yourself that doesn't
exist because if you guys keep dating
you know your true self is gonna come
out eventually and then they're gonna be
like wait I thought you were this super
clean you know organized sporty person
and here you are all you want to do is
do this and that all day and so not
pretending because you don't want
someone to
like you when you're not being you
that's kind of pointless you want them
to like you when you're being you
so
I feel like I can go on and on about
this topic yeah I mean it's okay so
personal hygiene being interested being
yourself eye contact anything else I
mean those are the very Basics and then
I think
I think also accepting the fact that
this may or may not be
something
that is going to
like there may or may not be a second
date so not putting too much pressure on
okay this has to go well and they have
to like me and what can I say to make
them want to see me again and rather
kind of seeing it as like do you like
them do you guys have chemistry like is
this do you feel like you could be
friends too instead of putting all this
pressure on this is going to be my next
girlfriend am I gonna marry this person
like sure if that's what you're looking
for you might have those questions in
the back of your mind but giving you
more of a chance of like okay this is
just someone I'm meeting and we're just
gonna see if we're vibing and if there
is something there that we want to keep
building on or not and try not to put
too much weight on it I think because
then you're going to be nervous and
stressed and that may
make you
behave in a way that isn't actually you
and that may ruin things
so try to keep the nerves in check and
which is hard
especially if you're interested because
you're going to be more nervous if you
see someone you're like oh wow this is
someone
that I feel I could be interested in
that's going to make you more nervous
but um
find a mantra maybe or something that
you keep telling yourself
like I'm just seeing this person another
human being and we're going to take it
as it goes
do you have any advice for women
it's a good question no
I've been on very few like bad dates
okay that's a bad day yeah that's the
thing I don't really know
um I've had like a few where
we just haven't really clicked yeah but
that's like really useful to know like
and there's nothing that I or them could
have done to force that connection yeah
I feel like most of the women I know
have had a lot worse experiences of like
being on a bad date yeah because like I
guess for a guy worst case scenario the
date's kind of boring for a girl worst
case scenario is like really bad so
um I think most women I know have had a
lot more yeah a lot their their share
about experiences yeah
and I think
not making the first date too
extravagant
because you don't want to put that
pressure on either of you
so
some people let's say the guy in this
example may think that it's impressive
asking a girl on a three meal course or
like a I don't know something that's
kind of over the top to somehow impress
her and again some women might enjoy
that personally for me and the like my
girlfriends and when we talked about
we're all we all agree on the fact that
the first date should be very simple
yeah like a walk and a coffee or
something like that like maybe like a
small picnic
not more than that because you also
don't want to put the pressure on her to
like stay throughout the three-course
meal let's say if none of you are
feeling it and I think the best way of
getting to know someone like getting
getting an idea of who someone is is
through doing something very simple
together such as taking a walk or a
coffee or like a small lunch at most I
think
what do you think do you think first
extravagant dates her room yeah not fun
I like I like doing doing something on
the first date okay some some people say
so um
one of the classic examples of dating
advice for guys that other guys would
say is never do lunch or coffee because
that creates a sort of platonic friends
kind of vibe whereas going for drinks or
dinner creates a little like at night
time there's just a little bit more of a
less of a we're just friends kind of
vibe I've always kind of ignored that
advice because I really like doing
lunches and breakfasts and brunches and
coffees
I'm not a huge fan of dinner on the
first date but yeah
no I don't think that either I mean I
think lunch or coffee is great I don't
think it has to be at night time sure
night time like inevitably kind of feels
more a little bit more intimate a bit
more romantic maybe but I think there's
something very
wholesome about like taking a morning
walk with someone or like meeting at
noon and grabbing a coffee yeah I much
prefer that approach because I feel like
for me anyway the sort of like most
interactions with the person are not
going to be intimate nighttime romantic
setting they're going to be like the
day-to-day what's it like grabbing a
coffee with you what's it like having
lunch exactly I think
setting that out on the first day and
just seeing seeing what that Vibe is
like yeah it's quite nice I agree
um you put out a video recently called
something like self-care is killing you
or something like that uh yeah I changed
the title so many times oh yeah oh okay
yeah
what is self-care and
what are your broadly broadly your
thoughts on the concept of self-care
I think with the self-care Trend my
definition of self-care also became like
doing a face mask and you know relaxing
and watching an episode of something
without feeling guilty and making a
green juice or you know reading a book
just for fun
um kind of the opposite of
working and the opposite of hustling and
all of that
and
to some extent you know I bought into it
but I think I bought into it too much
where I started feeling like
doing all these things weren't actually
making me feel good in the long run so
there are some things that make me feel
good in the long run like I actually
feel good when I work hard on a video
and I actually feel good when I have
um
something in my life go well that I've
been working on
that makes me feel good in the long run
even if in the moment I might feel
resistant like I feel good when I've
been working out consistently for a long
time and eating well and all of that and
in the moment that might feel like oh
well it's not self-care because you're
not actually wanting to do the thing you
would rather relax and you deserve to
relax and I think it's been very
emphasized that we should just relax and
we should you know we shouldn't work too
hard and we should take care of
ourselves and yes to some extent yes but
also
I think it's easy to let those things
become
a distraction and an escape like a an
excuse for not doing what you should be
doing in the name of self-care and I
think I fell into that and so now
self-care to me is
thinking is this serving future me or am
I escaping something right now like am I
putting on
a face mask when I should be working on
the script just because I deserve some
self-care
um
so yeah I think in
in a nutshell self-care to me right now
is just serving My Future Self
so sometimes that might be the face mask
but sometimes it might be actually
cranking up the video yeah like it's not
not self-care just because it feels a
bit difficult or because I feel
resistant because a lot of the good
things or things that
are going to be good for us in the long
run are things that are a bit
uncomfortable or where there is
resistant resistance in the moment
so I think I think that's okay and we
can lean into that and know that it's
going to give gave us like the benefits
may come in the long run rather than
um
rather than using self-care as a way to
escape from responsibility which I think
is easy to kind of fall into like oh
well I deserve this four hour break and
kind of I think it's easy falling into
that mindset
and it's like where do you draw the line
between I am taking care of myself and
relaxing and I'm procrastinating and
escaping what I should be doing
like how do you find that balance
hmm
I don't know so I like to
um
I
I don't like the phrase should be doing
um because usually that implies someone
else's priority rather than my own
sometimes it's a should be doing because
it's my own thing like
I shouldn't go through the McDonald's
drive-through at midnight because it's
generally eating that would be an
unhealthy choice and I want to be the
sort of person who eats healthy
but when it's the context of
oh I should film this video right now
I always have a bit of a an allergic
reaction to that because I think
back in the day when when the channel
was just starting out you know that I
was you know that consistency was was
very important
um
but I feel like over time
I don't know just just sort of thinking
out loud here but I sort of feel like I
already have enough
and
when I say I should film this video like
what who's who's this should behind that
is it me thinking I should film the
video because even though I don't want
to or I don't feel like it right now is
that I should film this video because
this is going to be a good video that's
going to cause growth which is going to
increase Revenue but it's like why am I
trying to grow why am I trying to raise
revenue like I already have enough like
and I get into this weird thing where
it's almost like
have you have you come have you come
across the midwit meme no say a lot okay
so I'm gonna try and describe it for
people out there so like imagine like a
bell curve okay and it's like an IQ bell
curve where you've got 100 IQ in the
middle you have like 60 IQ on one end
and you have like 150 IQ on the other
end and you have like a normal
distribution
and the meme is basically that like
the person who's like gotten like an IQ
of 60. would say
I just use Apple notes the person of an
iq150 also says I just use Apple notes
but the person in the middle is like I
use notion in Rome I never known this
and that I have my PKM system I have my
double cast on Etc it's all that [ __ ]
and it's like you know there is look I'm
on the other end of Mastery there is
Simplicity and it's like kind of Full
Circle kind of Vibes and I often think
of it as like there is there is a
version of the midweek of the midwit
meme whereby the person with I iq60 kind
of with all of the caveats aside that
this is just this is problematic I'm
just trying to describe a meme for God's
sake with all those caveats aside the
the person who is iq60 says I just do
what I feel like the person with iq150
says I just do what I feel like and the
person in the middle is like I manage my
to-do list to use my thing I've set up
my most important task every day I do my
getting things done method capture
colorful organized reflect engages
but actually like on the other side of
that there's like I just do what I feel
like doing and actually that works out
and so I'm trying to be more of that
that guy I'm trying to be more like
instead of coercing myself to do things
I don't want to do in the moment
let me just actually do what I feel like
because I think I've gotten to the point
where generally
even if I just do what I feel like
things are broadly okay but I don't know
if I'm yeah how's that with things like
working out
yeah so this is where this starts to
become a problem because like eating
healthy or things like that yeah so so
the way I think of it is that
okay so rewinding it um there is a
strategy that sociologists use to
run studies on whether life is worth
living
broadly so um if you ask people is your
life worth living most people would say
yes
um but you can't really take the word
for it because they're just being asked
in the moment it's just a single sample
of things so one strategy that some some
people use is they would give someone
like a pager or ring them like maybe 20
times in a day and they would ask the
question of like hey so you're taking
part in this study what are you doing
right now and they might be like I'm
making a cup of tea or I'm writing a
script for a video or I'm doing some
video editing or I'm working out and
then they would ask them
if you could press a button would you
fast forward to the end of this
experience
and you still get the benefit of the
experience but you don't have to
experience the experience okay
and they see what what percentage of
people like What proportion of your day
would you choose to fast forward oh
and I can't remember the exact stat but
it's a remarkably large percentage of
most people's workday they would choose
to fast forward yeah like even though I
enjoyed working as a doctor unless I was
teaching medical students which I would
not fast forward because it was fun I
couldn't wait to get to the end of the
workday I'd be like looking at the
company like 5 PM yes I can go home now
so I would choose to fast forward the
workday and actually if you were just to
fast forward 10 hours of your life every
day that's like it's pretty bad
um and so I I use this as a bit of a
model to guide am I living the sort of
life I want to be living I love that
um and I would choose to fast forward
working out with my personal trainer and
I recognized this a few weeks ago to be
like this is bad like
I should find a way to stay healthy and
exercise that I wouldn't choose to fast
forward like playing squash or tennis or
badminton rather than trying to bench
press because I'm like why am I trying
to get hinged because I think I'm kind
of trying to get six-pack abs I don't
know I already have a girlfriend so like
um
and so yeah I think the working out
thing is a bit of a problem okay
well do you tell yourself then that you
should be working out
or how do you tell yourself because you
don't want to tell yourself you should
be working right but what do you tell
yourself when it comes to working out or
staying healthy like how do you still do
the thing without getting the allowed
allergic reaction that you talked about
this it doesn't work 100 of the time but
but broadly I try and find a way to make
it more energizing or make it more
enjoyable in some way or I I choose I
tell myself a story that actually this
is the person I want to be and I want to
do this like this morning
when I was getting lunch it was a choice
between kind of the fried salmon or the
grilled mackerel and I was like I want
to be the sort of person that goes to
the grilled mackerel because I want to
live to 180 years old and I want to take
care of my health therefore I'm gonna go
for the grilled mackerel rather than I
should go for the grilled mackerel and
so again it's just a little bit of an
attitude change yeah but I find that the
word should implies a lack of autonomy
yeah and just removing the word should
or even the phrase like I don't have
enough time or I'm too busy like all of
these are phrases that remove the
the onus on us that we control our lives
and even just changing the phrasing of
that or I'm choosing not to make this a
priority
like I don't have time to learn language
exercise I'm choosing to not make a
priority right now yeah it just feels
way better even though it's exactly the
same thing yeah no I agree I also try to
change my phrasing sometimes but so with
the graph they were talking about like
the people on the
on each side of the graph are people who
say I don't need to do this thing or
yeah I just do what I feel like I just
do what I feel like so who do you think
are the people in the middle because I
feel like the people at the very end are
those who are in a position where let's
say like you like they're already
successful they can choose right so who
do you think are the people in the
middle oh yeah I was very much in the
middle yeah for most of my life where
like I sometimes didn't feel like doing
a video but I cranked it out anyway
because consistency is important and
because I knew I had this goal I was
working towards of financial
Independence
um but now that I've arrived at that
okay the Temptation is to be more growth
growth growth but I have to like what I
tell myself is actually no this is fine
okay I have enough so getting to that
point was that the financial
Independence that got you to a point
where you could be like I do what I feel
like was that there no that was always
that was always the goal like ever since
I read the four-hour Work Week
um back when I was like 17. yeah I was
like you know this is
this is the future that I want where I
can choose to work if I feel like it but
I don't have to so besides enjoying what
you're doing yeah how do you keep
staying motivated when you already have
what was your biggest goal with all of
this
which was Financial Independence
how do you continue finding meaning and
doing this
because you're doing a lot too it's not
just videos I mean you're
um it's a podcast yeah so many things
courses and all of that so what
continues to drive you
so let's put the courses aside because
the the thing that drives the courses is
I want to make more money so that I can
sustain the business et cetera et cetera
the thing that drives me now honestly is
that I want to be helpful to people and
and
the way I've I discovered this was I
asked myself what would I want written
on my gravestone
and the answer was three things good
father good husband and like
inspirational teacher or something like
that and then I asked myself okay what
do I want people to say at my funeral
like different sorts of people and close
friends family someone who's come across
my work
and I'd want people to say that like
I was watching all his YouTube channel
or I read Ellie's book or I listened to
his podcast and he taught me something
or he introduced me to an idea that then
changed my life
and so that's the thing that drives me
now of like
I get to be a teacher of two people and
I can learn cool [ __ ] and share stuff
with people and some of it helps and
some of it doesn't help and
like I'm that I'm I'm trying to not
allow money to be the motivator
but I think that's a thing I have to
constantly reaffirm to myself
because by default society and actually
really on this podcast I often interview
people who are like kind of deca
millionaires from selling their business
and stuff and it starts to become it's
it's easy to be like oh I wish I had 10
million plus in the back
and then you speak to them and they're
like I I often ask you know like are you
only happier not like that but
but it was fun and so it seems like even
the people who are stupidly successful
enjoy the process focused on the journey
and the result was almost inevitable
um so I'll try and keep that in mind
okay yeah how about you how do you
motivate yourself to do something when
you don't feel like it necessarily I
think
it's mainly two things and I think it's
both of the things that you mentioned so
the first thing is just sustaining what
I'm doing and being able to continue
doing it financially and
yeah something holding and potentially
getting some other people on board and
building more out of it and then
with that being said none of it would
mean anything if what I was doing wasn't
actually helping anyone
there would be no point and no
motivation
so I think it's those two things mainly
and even on bad days just reading a
comment from someone like if there's a
day when I'm like I just really don't
feel like
doing the same right now or writing or
editing or whatever it is and then I'll
because I have a folder with comments
that I've saved oh same really yeah yeah
from like comments that really were like
oh that's so nice that I've saved and
sometimes I'll look at that and be like
wow like someone wrote that after
watching something that I put out there
and so sometimes that's enough to just
fill me and want to continue so
um yeah so much of it is just a
community and the people
journaling yes you talk a lot about
journaling you've got a new skillshare
class about Memoir journaling yeah what
like what what is journaling what is
Memoir journaling why is it good so
I've been journaling
for ever I mean since I was I know eight
or nine well at the time it was keeping
a diary
um
writing about my day or who was gonna
invite to my birthday party or things
like that
um but also some pretty surprisingly
like
sort of insightful things like when I
look back about what I felt about my
friends or things like that
um but I've been journaling for so long
and I know for sure that I would not
have a YouTube channel had I not been
journaling because that's where I do so
much of my thinking and so much of that
is what creates the videos is things
that I've been writing about and
thinking about
um by writing about it
and so Memoir journaling is just a
concept that I made up which is
basically
writing about
a moment in time or it can be a present
moment it can be a past moment and
writing about it in a way like you're
telling a story about that moment and
you want that story to be as detailed
as possible and it's a way to not only
remember parts of your life through
instead of being like let's say you go
on a first date with someone and you
want to write a memoir journaling entry
about it instead of being like yeah we
grabbed a cup of coffee it was fun
um you go into more detail of like okay
what was the atmosphere were you sitting
at a cafe and what was the feeling there
and what could you see and was there
music playing and do you think that
music affected the mood and kind of
going into too much detail uh just to
really bring that moment to life and
what has helped me do is well partly
it's I think a beautiful thing keeping
an archive of having so many moments so
carefully
um documented
and also just helps me pay more
attention I think in everyday life and
notice things a bit more and appreciate
things more instead of just rushing
through life and kind of be
um oblivious to it's kind of like a stop
and smell the roses kind of thing in a
nutshell
and I know you Journal too right I've
been doubling for like I've done it on
and off for the last several years but I
really started taking it seriously about
like three or four months ago what do
you think are the benefits of journaling
oh it's so good it's like it's like
personal therapy yeah
um I find like
I asked myself how am I feeling right
now and then try and identify my
feelings and usually if there's
something negative and I feel a bit
weird oh yeah it's because the YouTube
video I recently put out didn't do very
well huh why do I feel weird about that
oh it's because I'm kind of worried that
blah blah blah blah and it's sort of
the spiral of I'm worried I'm going to
end up broken homeless and alone when
it's on paper I'm just like okay
obviously this is dumb and like I can
choose not to feel like that and then
that helps kind of reaffirm this thing
around I can't just make videos what I
want about what I want and I don't need
to worry about sponsors or about this or
about that and so journaling is like
almost that daily like meditation to
reaffirm a particular like affirmation
or something yeah like it gives you
perspective yeah that you wouldn't have
otherwise yeah I think that's super
helpful yeah have you got any tips for
people who might be listening to this
and yeah cool journaling sounds fun yeah
I think it's a little bit like the
starting YouTube channel thing where I
get questions like what should I journal
on and do you recommend the specific
notebook or you know all these things
that just kind of make you not do the
thing because you're so worried about
all the things surrounding the thing
that you actually want to be doing so I
think just not putting too much
energy and thought into what pen should
I write with and should I write on my
computer or just like open up your notes
up and write five sentences or what or
what you're feeling like or what's on
your mind and don't overthink it
um I Journal everywhere I have my
notebook I have Google Docs I have a
Notes app on my phone which probably has
most of my journal entries at this
moment because very in the moment and
you don't want to think about it too
much so just getting started and
it's a bit of cringe as well some people
are like oh that's so cringy I can't
write about what I'm feeling and
it's kind of embarrassing sometimes just
viewing your own thoughts because
sometimes they don't make sense or
sometimes you don't want to feel that
way and so I think just putting that
aside and being a bit nicer to yourself
and being like it's totally fine to feel
its way even if it's not something that
I'm proud of or that I would want to
share because you don't want to have to
share it you can just keep it yourself
and that's what most people do with
their journaling entries
so getting over the cringe and the
overthinking and just start writing and
see where it takes you and also don't
worry about your handwriting or like
using the right words or not making it
look messy or you know I think the
perfectionism
um is something that
can delay a lot of things in life such
as journaling or starting a Channel or
whatever it is that you want to do so
I'm just letting some of that go and
going for it because
there's not going to be a negative
outcome like nothing's going to happen
because you broke down a few sentences
in your notes up you'll be fine
yeah I think there's a lot of value in
actually
identifying our own feelings about the
things which we might not be admitting
to ourselves but when it's on paper then
it's just like oh yeah I understand
myself a bit better now
and I found that like it also makes life
slow down a bit in that
um one thing I do with the bullet
Journal these days is every day at the
end in the evening not almost every day
I write down a few things I'm grateful
for and I'll write down um based on
Matthew Dix's book storyworthy uh what
is one story worthy moment that happened
today
and I have this little look and I've
been doing this for the last like two
weeks uh last four weeks and sort of
dabbled with it on and off in different
different periods as well and whenever I
have that practice of nightly journaling
what happened today
it feels like time slows down because
now I'm like oh
I actually am reflecting on my day and
thinking about what happened and I could
be thinking about it and then I can look
back through the list and be like oh
yeah it feels like this month flew by
but actually it didn't because all this
stuff happened and that's really cool
yeah so that's a nice nice experience
and what do you what have you experience
have been the benefits of gratitude
journaling like writing down the things
you're grateful for honestly none yet
um yeah I think it's supposed to be the
benefits
there's some some people really swear by
it uh there was a huberman lab episode
where he looked into the signs behind
this he said that uh it doesn't really
hold up
um oh okay but I mean enough people do
it that anecdotally they always say that
oh it helps you just be more
appreciative of be sort of and it's that
smell the roses moment and like a nice
easy way
um so I do try and focus on like the
small things that are nice
but I think I'm broadly good at being
grateful for Stuff uh not like outwardly
but inwardly okay like how do you know
that uh so there's that quote I think
from Victor Frankel which is where
you know whenever you're feeling
particularly content remind yourself
that you know if if this isn't nice I
don't know what is
and I will often remind myself of that
or I just remember that thought when
something particularly fun is happening
like this morning I was sitting in a
coffee shop doing working on my book
introduction with a little flat white I
was like huh if this is a nice little I
can't believe this is my job like this
is sick yeah really good when I'm having
when I do a podcast interviews sometimes
that thought comes into my mind you're
like oh like when you said earlier that
this is our job yeah I was like oh this
is sick and just those moments of like
oh this is actually really cool like
this is the life that I've been aspiring
to and now I have that life so I should
enjoy it while it's here yeah
how do you think people can stay
grateful even when they're not actually
living the life that they want like when
they're not living the dream yeah
um I mean I can't pretend to offer
advice on this but I will cite Mo gauda
who's uh has done loads of research into
happiness he said that
uh the key is to compare down rather
than compare up okay because it's very
easy to compare yourself to someone who
is quote made it and be like oh I don't
I don't have that lifestyle yeah but
really there's a lot of benefits you get
from comparing down and being like I'm
so glad I have a roof over my head I'm
so glad I'm not living in poverty right
now like I'm so glad like and and in a
way
being grateful for the fact that you're
alive and in good health and yeah have a
job and or like whatever that thing
might be yeah and there's always people
out there who have worse than you and so
as crass as it sounds like comparing
yourself to them is way easier to be
grateful than comparing yourself to the
influencer on Instagram who's got five
million followers
yeah yeah how do you think about that I
think I just remind myself kind of the
way that you described like what I said
about sitting here or if I'm spending
time with someone who's making me very
happy I'll be like wow I can't believe I
have this person in my life or
this yeah those reminders and I think
when you do it enough they're kind of
automatic you don't really even have to
think about oh wait I should remind
myself at the end of the day what I'm
grateful for because you've kind of
trained your brain into
appreciating things throughout the day
and
yeah those reminders kind of come
automatically especially when things
aren't going well and you're happy it's
a bit harder when you feel like things
aren't going well and you
you aren't feeling that well it's a bit
more difficult finding things to be
grateful for even if there's always
something to be grateful for but it's a
bit more challenging but
yeah I think uh just a small moments and
being like wow I can't believe
I get to be in London today and I can't
believe you know just appreciating that
not taking things for granted
any um so changing gears a bit are there
any books that you've read that have had
a big impact on your life to date yeah
so I always say my favorite book is
Stoner by John Williams oh it's a novel
I'll check it out uh which might be
surprising you might think that a
self-help book or a non-fiction at least
would have the biggest impact on your
life but audible right now
um it's a great book I wish I could read
it again like for the first time
um and I don't even really know why
because
it's not a book where a lot is happening
or where it's this dramatic thing where
you're gonna find out what's gonna
happen later and it's a very
it's a very simple book with very
beautiful writing
um
and I think it changed my life in a way
that it just made me
see the beauty in Simplicity in a way
that I hadn't really seen it before and
it made me think about how fascinating
people's lives
are even if they're not living
a
extravagant lifestyle like everyone's
story is interesting somehow like
there's so much happening in everyone's
lives all the time even those who thinks
that those who think that their lives
are boring or that they're not
experiencing enough things like just
being alive and going about your day
like there are always things that I
think are
fascinating to learn about anyone even
if on paper they're not like a
business owner or they're not someone
who was achieved XYZ and you know I
think that's what the book kind of made
me realize because the main character
Stoner he's a he's living a very average
life yet it's filled with so much
emotion and
so many lessons so I think that's what
threw me into it nice I'll start
listening to it on Audible today yeah
thank you very much let me know what you
thought well thank you so much this has
been absolutely wonderful
um any final message for people who
might have listened to the three hours
of this is it yeah it's like five
o'clock now we started recording at like
two that's crazy yeah any any final
potting words of wisdom
um ooh words of wisdom that sounds like
or just anything I'm a philosopher I'm a
philosopher yeah Seneca and all that I
think just uh
final words of wisdom
I just don't like seeing people waste
their potential
that's one of my pet peeves
and
I just want people to try the thing that
they're thinking about
is that starting a Channel or changing
your major or moving out whatever it is
that's this itch that you have in your
body and in your mind where you're like
I can't get this thing out of my mind
this is your sign to try it and go for
it and um
see what happens ready well thank you
very much we'll put links to all your
stuff in the show notes and in the video
description and thank you so much for
coming on thank you for having me all
right so that's it for this week's
episode of Deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye